the latest is that it is spreading fast
and the head of the CDC warns the US
will probably face one of its biggest
public health emergencies before the end
of this year as it deals with both kovat
19 and the flu at the same time oh boy
many Americans are desperate for answers
as you know look at these long lines in
several states hundreds of cars just
sitting there waiting to be tested yeah
they at least three states Alabama Utah
and Florida just reported a record
one-day number of corona rot virus
related deaths our lead national
correspondent David Begg know is in
Orlando David good morning Anthony good
morning Florida saw its largest increase
in hospitalizations yesterday more than
any other state 300 people went into the
hospital just yesterday with coronavirus
this morning you're gonna hear from the
man who is leading the state's effort
we're in the middle of hurricane season
he's used to dealing with hurricanes
stuff right now but he says over the
last 90 days coronaviruses responds here
in Florida has consumed more time and
resources than a category 5 hurricane
but what's interesting he says is during
a hurricane everybody for the most part
is on the same page get out or stay safe
and hunker down he says in this case
it's based on what your political
persuasion is or who you're getting your
information from
and he says almost no one is on the same
page working hurricanes or Sprint's this
thing is a marathon that is Jerrod
Moskowitz director of Florida's Division
of Emergency Management his agency is at
the center of the state's coronavirus
response setting up testing sites
delivering critical supplies and
allocating personnel across Florida he
says this is the largest operation in
state history and it has been
complicated by misinformation and
politics when a category 5 hits nobody
argues whether it was a category 5 no
one says no it was a category 2 and in
this disaster we're arguing over
everything in miami-dade more than 30%
of all coronavirus tests came back
positive on Tuesday and with
hospitalizations surging Miami's mayor
says more roll backs may be necessary
you know there is
sniffing amount of pressure right now
for us to shut down at some level out
west it is a similar story in Los
Angeles County new cases and
hospitalizations hit record highs
Tuesday listen to what the LA mayor Eric
Garcetti said before those numbers were
announced red is when it's everything
shuts down again everything to our
strictest level and so I do want to warn
people that were close to that the
outbreak is also accelerating in South
Carolina on Tuesday Senator Lindsey
Graham was briefed by hospital
administrators this is what he had to
say afterwards we see a dramatic
increase in the number of cases and
hospitals are facing severe staffing
shortages with the national outbreak
still raging the city of Philadelphia
now says it will not allow any public
gatherings over 50 people until early
2021 officials say that could include
crowds at professional sporting events
this season the director of the CDC dr.
Robert Redfield warns that the worst may
still be ahead when the pandemic
combines with the flu season I do think
the fall in the winter of 2020 and 2021
are gonna be the probably one of the
most difficult times that we've
experienced American public health that
is George Guerrero his 39 year old
sister Renata McGuire died two weeks
after being hospitalized with
coronavirus he says she was a devoted
mother to six children now he's caring
for them along with four of his own it's
still hard to deal with man you know she
should still be here Ranade did have
underlying conditions with her kidneys
that she had been treated for before she
felt sick with the coronavirus back here
in the state of Florida they are doing
record testing but they are still
dealing with the problem of getting test
results back fast enough
Tony the head of the Emergency
Management Agency told us yesterday they
have more than 12 contracts with 12
different companies to keep testing
people he said at one point a company
called and said listen it's too many
tests it's taking us too much don't send
us any more tests for 48 hours
he basically fired them on the spot and
said go find me somebody better who can
do it faster
because the demand requires that it's
good news David the testing is not too
effective if you don't get those results
quickly thank you very much